i believe you've written drake
uh there's a team of people i'm i
certainly spend a lot of hours on it
myself
well what is drake and what um what does
it take to
to to create a simulation environment
uh for for the kind of difficult control
problems we're talking about
right so drake is the simulator that
that i've been working on
um there are other good simulators out
there i don't like to think of drake as
just a simulator
because because we write our controllers
in drake we write our perception systems
a little bit in drake
but we write all of our our you know low
level control and even planning
and optimization into his optimization
capabilities absolutely
yeah i mean drake is three things
roughly it's an optimization library
which is um sits on it it
provides a layer of abstraction in c
plus and python
for commercial solvers you can write
linear programs quadratic programs you
know semi-definite programs
sums of squares programs the ones we've
used mixed integer programs
and it will do the work to curate those
and send them to
whatever the right solver is for
instance and it provides a level of
abstraction
the second thing is is a system modeling
language
a bit like labview or simulink where you
can make block diagrams out of complex
systems or it's like ross in that sense
where
you might have lots of ross nodes that
are each doing some part of your system
but to contrast it with ross
we try to write if you write a drake
system then you have to
it asks you to describe a little bit
more about the system if you have any
state for instance in the system there
any variables that are going to persist
you have to declare them
parameters can be declared and the like
but the advantage of doing that
is that you can if you like run things
all on one process
but you can also do control design
against it you can do
i mean simple things like rewinding and
playing back your
your um your simulations for instance
you know these things you get some
rewards for spending a little bit more
upfront cost in describing each system
um and and i i was inspired to do that
because i think the complexity of atlas
for instance
it's just so great and i think although
i mean ross has been incredible
absolutely huge fan of what it's done
for the robotics
community but it um
the ability to rapidly put different
pieces together and have a functioning
thing is very good but i do think
that it's hard to think clearly about a
bag of
disparate parts mr potato head kind of
software stack
and if you can
you know ask a little bit more out of
each of those parts then you can
understand their the way they work
better you can
try to verify them and the like
you can do learning against them and
then one of those systems the last thing
i
i said the first two things the drake is
but the last thing is that there is a
set of multi-body equations rigid body
equations
that is trying to provide a system that
simulates physics
and that um we also have renderers and
other things but i think this
physics component of drake is is special
in the sense that
um we have done excessive amount of
engineering
to to make sure that we've written the
equations correctly every possible
tumbling satellite or spinning top or
anything that we could possibly write as
a test is tested
we are making some you know i think
fundamental
improvements on the way you simulate
contact just what does it take to uh
simulate contact i mean it just seems uh
i mean there's something just beautiful
the way you were like explaining
contact and you're like tapping your
fingers on the on the table while you're
while you're doing it just um easily
right
easily just like just not even like
it was like helping you think i guess um
what i i um see you have this like
awesome demo of um
loading or unloading a dishwasher
just picking up a plate
grasping it like for the first time
that just seems like so difficult
what how do you simulate any of that
so so it was really interesting that
what happened was that um
we started getting more professional
about our software development during
the darpa robotics challenge
i learned the value of software
engineering and how these
how to bridle complexity i guess that's
that's what i want to somehow
fight against and bring some of the
clear thinking of controls into
these complex systems we're building for
robots
shortly after the darpa robotics
challenge toyota opened a research
institute
tri toyota research institute they put
one of their there's there's three
locations one of them is just down the
street from mit
and uh and i helped ramp that up
uh right as a part of my uh
the end of my sabbatical i guess um so
so tri is uh
has given me the tri robotics effort has
made this investment in simulation
in drake and michael sherman leads a
team there of just
absolutely top notch dynamics experts
that are trying to write those
simulators that can pick up the dishes
and there's also a team
working on manipulation there that is
taking
problems like loading the dishwasher and
we're using that
to study these really hard corner cases
kind of problems in manipulation
so for me this um you know simulating
the dishes we could actually write a
controller if we just cared about
picking up dishes in the sink once we
could write a controller without any
simulation whatsoever
and we could call it done but we want to
understand like
what is the path you take to actually
get to
a robot that could perform that for any
dish
in anybody's kitchen with with enough
confidence that it could be
a commercial product right and and
it has deep learning perception in the
loop it has complex dynamics in the loop
it has controller it has a planner
and how do you take all of that
complexity
and put it through this engineering
discipline and verification
and validation process to actually get
enough confidence to deploy i mean the
darpa challenge
made me realize that that's not
something you throw over the fence and
hope that somebody will harden it
for you that there are really
fundamental challenges
in uh in closing that last gap they're
doing the validation
and the testing i think it might even
change the way we have to think about
the way we write systems
what happens if you if you have the
robot
running lots of tests it and it
screws up it breaks a dish right how do
you capture that i said you can't run
the same simulation or the same
experiment twice
in in a real on a real robot do we have
to be able to bring that
one off exp failure back into simulation
in order to change our controllers
study it make sure it won't happen again
do we
is it enough to just try to add that to
our distribution
and understand that on average we're
going to cover that situation again
there's like really subtle questions at
the corner cases
that i think we don't yet have
satisfying answers for
like how do you find the corner cases
that's one kind of
is there do you think this possible to
create a systematized way
of discovering corner cases efficiently
yeah in whatever the problem is yes
i mean i think we have to get better at
that i mean control theory has
for for decades talked about active
experiment design
so people call it curiosity these days
it's roughly this idea of trying to
exploration or exploitation but but in
the active experiment design is even
is is more specific you could try to
understand the uncertainty in your
system design the experiment that will
provide the maximum information to
reduce that uncertainty
if you there's a parameter you want to
learn about what is the optimal
trajectory i could execute to learn
about that parameter
for instance scaling that up to
something that has a deep network in the
loop and the planning in the loop is
tough
we've done some work on you know with
matt o'kelly and aman cena
we've worked on some falsification
algorithms that are trying to do rare
event simulation that try to just hammer
on your simulator
and if your simulator is good enough you
can um
you can spend a lot of time er you can
write good algorithms
that try to spend most of their time in
the corner cases
so you basically imagine you're you're
building um an autonomous car and you
want to put it in
i don't know downtown new delhi all the
time right an accelerated testing
if you can write sampling strategies
which figure out where your controller
is performing badly in simulation
and start generating lots of examples
around that
you know it's just the space of possible
places where that can be
where things can go wrong is very big so
it's hard to write those algorithms
yeah rare event simulation is just like
a really compelling notion
uh if it's possible we joked and we
called we call it the black swan
generator
it's a black swan right because you
don't just want the rare events you want
the ones that are highly
impactful i mean that's the most
those are the most sort of profound
questions we ask of our world like
uh what's the what's the worst that can
happen
but what we're really asking isn't some
kind of like computer science worst case
analysis
we're asking like what are the millions
of ways
this can go wrong and that's like our
curiosity
we humans i think are pretty bad at uh
we just like run into it and i think
there's a distributed sense because
there's now
like 7.5 billion of us and so there's a
lot of them and then
a lot of them write blog posts about the
stupid thing they've done so we learn
in a distributed way um there's there's
something that's going to be important
for robots too yeah
i mean that's that's another massive
theme at
toyota research for robotics is this
fleet learning concept
is um you know the idea that
i as a humanoid don't have enough time
to visit all of my states right there's
just a
it's very hard for one robot to
experience all the things
but that's not actually the problem we
have to solve right um
we're going to have fleets of robots
that can have very similar appendages
and at some point maybe collectively
they have
enough data that their computational
processes should be set up differently
than ours right
it's a this vision of just i mean all
these
dishwasher unloading robots
i mean that robot dropping a plate
and a human looking at the robot
probably pissed off
yeah but uh that's a special moment to
record
i think one thing in terms of fleet
learning
and i've seen that because i i've talked
to a lot of folks
just like like tesla users or tesla
drivers
they're not another another company
that's using this kind of fleet learning
idea
one hopeful thing i have about humans is
they
really enjoy when a system improves
learns so they enjoy fleet learning and
they're
the reason it's hopeful for me is
they're willing to put up with
something that's kind of dumb right now
and they're like
if it's improving they almost like enjoy
being part of the like teaching it
almost like if you have kids like you're
teaching or something right
um i think that's a beautiful thing
because that that gives me hope that we
can put
dumb robots out there uh as long i mean
the problem with the
on the tesla side with cars cars can
kill you
that's that makes the problem so much
harder dishwasher
unloading is a little safe that's why
home robotics is uh
it's really exciting
you